Down the ages past, Allah sent his
messengers to deliver humankind from
darkness to light.
Invite all to the way of thy Lord with
wisdom and beautiful preachings, and
argue with them in the ways that are
best and most gracious.
That's also the ongoing mission of
Islamic Research Foundation or IRF,
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to mankind.
Founded in 1991,
IRF today offers some of the best
services and facilities in the world for
presenting an understanding of Islam in
an objective and scientific way.
Its programs are primarily focused on
correcting misconceptions and promoting
understanding of Islam.
IRF also imparts Dawah training to Dais
to aptly convey the message of Islam.
IRF has one of the most modern studios
producing programs presenting Islam,
which are beamed regularly on many
international TV channels in over 150
countries.
Dr. Zakir Naik, president of IRF,
reaching out across countries worldwide
from America to Europe to Africa to Asia
to Australia, strives to clarify Islamic
viewpoints. He dispels the many media
myths and anti-Islamic prejudices
propagated the world over by
anti-Islamic forces. Dr. Zakir Naik is a
medical doctor.
He's acclaimed the world over for his
spontaneous and convincing replies to
questions posed by critics and skeptics
during the question and answer sessions
after his talks.
He's also renowned for his verbatim
quotes with references from major
religious scriptures of the world.
Dr. Zakir and other faculty of the IRF
train many dais in effective Dawah
techniques.
IRF's website provides free Dawah
training material for you to download
and become an effective dai yourself.
Dr. Zakir Naik's talks are available on
audio and video cassettes, CDs, and DVDs
the world over.
IRF today is creating a change in the
hearts and minds of millions of Muslims
and non-Muslims worldwide towards a
proper understanding and respect for
Islam.
Have a question or doubt about Islam and
its teachings? Now you know one of the
best resource centers to get convincing
answers from is Islamic Research
Foundation.
56/58 Tandel Street, North Dongri,
Mumbai 400009,
India. Phone 2373-6875.
Fax 91-22-2373-0689.
Email islam@irf.net.
For more information, log on to our
website www.irf.net.
In the name of God,
most gracious, most merciful.
Mr. Y. P. Trivedi,
the chief guest of the evening,
Mr. Rashmibhai Zaveri,
Dr. Zakir Naik,
Mr. Chamanlal Vora,
Mr. Dhanraj Salecha,
distinguished guests,
ladies and gentlemen, As-salamu alaykum.
May peace be on you.
On behalf of the organizers,
the Indian Vegetarian Congress,
the Islamic Research Foundation, and the
Rushda Foundation,
I welcome all of you today
to this morning's unique program,
a public dialogue on the topic
is non-vegetarian food permitted or
prohibited for a human being?
It is being held in a spirit of
friendship and understanding each
other's viewpoints.
I, Dr. Muhammad Naik, am the coordinator
for this dialogue.
Hence,
I occupy a neutral position.
It is my onerous duty
to ensure a fair and proper conduct of
this meeting.
Therefore,
I would request
both our speakers as well as the
audience to maintain due decorum for a
healthy and lively debate
as well as a dialogue.
Now we would have
the past president of the Indian
Vegetarian Congress, Mr. Jayantilal R.
Doshi,
welcoming and introducing the chief
guest of the evening, Mr. YP Trivedi.
Mr. Jayantilal Doshi.
Mr. YP Trivedi,
he is a very senior advocate in Supreme
Court of India
and leading tax expert of Mumbai.
His activity in economic field inside
ex-president of Indian Mercantile
Chambers
and active members
of chairman of many other institute,
trade, and industrial body.
In
professional field, he was president of
Chambers of IT
consultant and vice president of IT
tribunal and bar association.
In political field, he is
traders of Maha Pradesh Congress
Committee, BRCC.
He is also chairman and director of many
public limited company,
Reliance and Dena Bank.
In education field,
he was
location of
matters degree in lower and Bombay
University.
He regularly continues article of
various
sympathy in different papers and
journalists.
He has addressed a
member of senior and meeting of Rotary,
Lions Club,
etc. and Air India and Doordarshan, etc.
Thank you.
Now, we have
Mr. Dhanraj Salecha, president of the
Rushab Foundation
presenting mementos to our chief guest,
as well as garlanding him on behalf of
the organizers.
Now, we have
our chief guest, Mr. Y.P. Trivedi
addressing our audience collected here
today. Mr. Y.P. Trivedi.
Dr. Zakir Naik,
Mr. Rashmi Zaveri,
Dr. Muhammad Naik,
Dr. Dhanraj Salecha,
Chimanlal Vora,
and
friends.
I
welcome
all the speakers
and all of you here
to this very healthy debate
which is taking place.
I believe
that this should be
the beginning
of similar debates
which should take place
in the times to come.
This debate
or discussion
or the clearinghouse of mind
is probably in the best traditions
both
of
the Hindu civilization
as well as of Islam.
In
our mythology and our history,
we have such instances
of such debates taking place
in the courts of kings like Janak.
When people from various schools of
thoughts, because Hinduism was never
following one particular pattern of
thinking.
There was Bhakti Marg, there was
non-dualism, there was Advaita Marg,
there was Charvakas who did not believe
in any God. So, all of them
Janak king King Janak used to assemble
them,
provoking them to debate,
not trying to influence anybody, but
inviting the thoughts and then leaving
the debate to the people at large to
make up their own mind.
So, that was the tradition of our Hindu
religion in this land of India.
That was also the tradition of Islam.
In the immediately succeeding years
after the demise of Prophet
Mahmud, Arabia was the place of
learning.
Logics, mathematics, astronomy, all this
was being discussed and the great
scholars of Arabia imbibed the thought,
made inquiries, and transformed that
knowledge thereafter to the Western
world.
According to me,
the Renaissance movement
in Europe owes its origin to the
thinking of these Arab thinkers who were
great stalwarts in their own time.
We very often associate
Arabia with thinking about Arabian
nights.
But let me tell you that apart from the
strides which they made in the field of
fiction and some of the most imaginative
fictions, at the same time in the field
of science, technology, thinking,
logics, mathematics, they made great
strides. That is why today also,
in spite of all the achievements, the
West is still talking about the numerals
as the Arabic numerals.
And this is how Islam also in those days
used to think openly.
This that tradition has been continued
because I believe in the realm of realm
of King Akbar. He also used to call
people from all religions, even the
Christians who came at that time. They
landed on the shore of India. They were
also called and they were asked to
explain what are the tenets of the
religion. So, this sort of healthy
debate is something which is an absolute
necessity for the development of any
cultured, civilized, and tolerant
society.
Dr. Waraich said that he is neutral.
Let me tell him and all of you, I am
also neutral.
If I would not have been neutral, I
would not have been made the chief
guest.
And do not wish to desire
to make any final comment on the
subject.
But one school of thought
I would like to narrate here,
which I read at some place,
that all those animals
in nature
who are grass eaters,
the animals which are thriving on
leaves,
they have got bovine teeth.
They do not have canine teeth.
All those animals
which are eating flesh, meat eaters,
they have got canine teeth.
What we call rakshi.
Human being is the one species
which has got both bovine teeth as well
as canine teeth.
It is very likely
that nature wanted this species to
survive. Nature considered this species,
human beings, are the most important
species which should
be there in this world. They should try
to contribute. They should try to carry
my message and take it further.
So, they wanted the nature probably
wanted this species to survive under all
circumstances.
Nobody can deny
that the early Homo sapiens or Homo
erectus,
they're all flesh eaters. At that time,
there was no agriculture. If you look at
the evolution as we now learn from
science,
it is only the advanced
advance of civilization
that people started taking to
agriculture. When they started taking to
agriculture and started growing corns,
some of them became vegetarian, some of
them remained non-vegetarian, some of
them became the mixture of both. They
also took vegetarian as well as
non-vegetarian. And most of the
non-vegetarian people today also eat
vegetarian food as a part of the diet.
I believe
that in this aspect, when you are
talking whether it is permitted or
prohibited, we are talking about
permission or prohibition by the
religion.
In this one aspect,
Dr. Naik, I would probably like to
differ from you.
I believe that it is not
the function of religion to tell us what
we should eat and what we should not
eat.
Religion should try to purify our soul,
purify our conscience, talk about good
behavior, lead us to the path of God.
What we should eat, what we should not
eat is something which the doctors
should tell us. The nutrition experts
should tell us. It is not the function
of the religion to say you shall not eat
garlic, you shall not eat onions, you
shall not eat ginger. Because this is
something if subsequently the
nutritional experts tell us that this is
something which is very good for your
health, which is very good for your
survival, which is very good for you to
fight your diseases, then certainly it
has to be taken.
Because these are the subjects in modern
day science. We have to grow up. We have
to think in terms of what is lying ahead
of us. We are entering now the next
millennium, 21st century. So much is
expected from us. Today only I was
reading in one of the magazines about
the forecast of Nostradamus.
And Nostradamus thinks that this
particular country
which is surrounded on three sides by
sea, that one country will come on the
top of the world. And are we going to go
into the top of the world, become a
superpower by just clinging ourselves to
some of the outdated notions? For
example, yesterday so many people
migrated from this country.
I was wondering in the heart of my
heart, what is it there's no scientific
explanation all throughout all people
with any basis of logic, all people who
knew something about science, they were
saying nothing will happen whether eight
planets come in one line or they go
zigzag. Nothing is going to happen. But
then all types of talks were there.
Alang, which was our largest shipyard,
that was completely forsaken and
completely deserted. I was told that for
rushing to Rajasthan, I believe I don't
understand why people from Rajasthan are
so panicky.
The Marwaris left everything, came here
and made an empire.
And the same Marwaris thinking the eight
planets are there, they ran away. I was
told 2,500 rupees were paid for a bus
ticket
for going back to Rajasthan.
And nothing happened.
So what is very important for all of us
if this country has to go further,
if we as a nation has to make our mark,
and probably the destiny is before us.
We can reach great strides. 21st
century, as I've always been saying,
belongs to India and Pakistan. Both of
them, when they will come nearer and
nearer, they will be able to become the
leaders of the 21st century.
And if that is going to happen, then let
me tell you, we will have to get out of
these old dogmas.
What we should eat, we should not eat,
the doctor should tell us. If a new
scientific discovery is made, and I've
been asked that I should eat tomatoes
because it fights fights the cancerous
growth, then I must eat tomatoes,
irrespective of what what my religion
tell me. So, I think let us go to the
scientist. Let us develop for ourselves
a modern mind, a scientific approach,
then I think today or tomorrow, the
whole world is before us. I don't want
to comment on the or trespass on the
domain of the speakers. With this
introductory remarks, I'm once again
trying to point out I am absolutely
neutral. And I would like to hear the
views of the learned people who have
made research on the subject. Thank you
very much.
Thank you, Mr. Trivedi.
Now, we have brief introductions of each
of the speakers before we get into the
mode of formal dialogue program.
We have Mr. Chamanbai Vora, senior vice
president of the Indian Vegetarian
Congress, to introduce Mr. Rashmibhai
Zaveri.
Well,
today I feel very happy to introduce our
president, Shri Rashmibhai Zaveri,
president of the
Indian Vegetarian Congress.
I think our
this public dialogue will become very
very interesting looking to the
introductory speech given by our chief
learned
guest, Shri
Trivedi.
So, let us hope for the very good
dialogue.
Now, Rashmibhai Zaveri is a
chartered accountant by profession.
He is having his own firm,
Rashmi Zaveri and Company.
They are very well reputed as far as the
corporate sector is concerned.
And he's a very good speaker
as far as the religious speeches are
concerned. He's a master of many of the
religious philosophies.
He's a very active member of the
Chartered Accountants Society.
Himself is the member of the Bharat Jain
Mahamandal.
He's the founder president of the Forum
of Jain Intellectuals, one of the very
prominent institution as far as the Jain
people are concerned.
And he's
very well connected with the Kala
Gurjari also.
Though he is very young at the age of
63, he is very energetic.
And
he looks forward always to this type of
dialogues and today's dialogue
is really very good one.
And I specially before by giving the
introduction of Mr.
Rashmi Jhaveri I would like to thank our
chief guest as well as our Dhanraj ji
and our Zakir Naik Saab
for having a very good dialogue
whether
by principle a human being can take or
should not take the vegetarian and
non-vegetarian foods. Thank you very
much.
Mr. Ashraf Mohamadi to introduce Dr.
Zakir Naik.
Dr. Zakir Abdul Karim Naik 33 years is
the president of the Islamic Research
Foundation, Mumbai.
Though a medical doctor by professional
training
he is renowned as a dynamic
international orator on Islam and
comparative religion.
Dr. Zakir
removes misconceptions about Islam on
the basis of Quran, Hadith and religious
scriptures of various other religions.
He also uses reason, logic, and modern
scientific facts to remove the
misconceptions about Islam.
He is popular
for his critical analysis
and convincing answers to challenging
questions posed by audiences after his
public talks.
In the last 3 years itself, he has
delivered more than 300 public talks
worldwide.
Dr. Zakir
also appears on various international TV
and satellite TV channels throughout the
world.
He has also
participated in various symposias and
such dialogues with prominent
personalities of various faiths.
I have been asked by many persons,
"Why are we having this dialogue?
This topic,
these speakers only?"
I hereby clarify.
Mr. Dhanraj Salecha, President of Rishab
Foundation,
once visited the Islamic Research
Foundation office about 1 and 1/2 month
ago.
He presented
the Islamic Research Foundation kindly
with a set of literature
favoring vegetarianism.
These included quotations from major
world religions,
which included quotations also from the
Quran
and sayings of Prophet Muhammad, peace
be upon him, which according to him
indicate
that non-vegetarian food is prohibited
for human beings.
After some discussions,
Mr. Salecha proposed
that
a public dialogue
be held
at Patkar Hall
between Mr. Rashmibhai Zaveri, president
of the Indian Vegetarian Congress, and
Dr. Zakir Naik, president of Islamic
Research Foundation,
on the topic
is
non-vegetarian food permitted or
prohibited for a human being?
This would
in turn enable the audience at large
to know
the different viewpoints of both the
speakers and form their own judgment.
Both the speakers agreed to the same.
Just about 5 days back, that is this
Tuesday,
I met Mr. Zaveri,
and he requested
that both the speakers
in their talk refrain from speaking
on other religions except their own.
Dr. Zakir, though being
very ardently in the field of
comparative religion, reluctantly
agreed.
Therefore,
as far as
the religious points are concerned in
the talk and response of our speakers,
Mr. Zaveri will speak
only from the Jain viewpoint unless
compelled otherwise.
Similarly, Dr. Zakir will speak only
from the Islamic viewpoint unless
compelled otherwise.
This in brief
is the clarifying background to the
dialogue.
The format for the dialogue will be
as agreed to and decided fair by the
speakers.
Mr. Rashmibhai Zaveri
will first
address us for 50 minutes on the topic
is non-vegetarian food permitted or
prohibited for a human being?
Then Dr. Zakir Naik
will make his presentation for 50
minutes on the same topic.
This would be followed by a response
session
in which
Mr. Zaveri will respond for 15 minutes
to the matter presented by Dr. Zakir.
Similarly, Dr. Zakir too would then
respond for 15 minutes to the matter
presented by Mr. Zaveri.
When 5 minutes are left
for the conclusion of the talk or the
response time, I would put before each
speaker a plate saying 5 minutes left in
which time they are expected to
conclude.
Lastly, we would have the question and
answer session in which the audience may
pose questions to each of the speakers
alternately
on the question mics provided in the
auditorium.
Written questions on slips of paper
would be given secondary preference
if time allows us.
Now,
I would request our first speaker,
Mr. Rashmibhai Zaveri, to present his
address.
Ladies and gentlemen, Mr. Rashmibhai
Zaveri.
Before I
start my talk,
I'm really very happy
that this atmosphere
of brotherhood
it has really moved me.
And I will request
Dr. Zakir Naik
to come forward and let's have a gale
lag jaa scene.
The chief guest
of this morning
Mr. Y.P. Trivedi
President of Rushab Corporation
Shri Dhanraj Salecha
the learned speaker
Dr. Zakir Naik
the expert commentator
and the coordinator
Dr. Muhammad Naik
Vice President of IVC Shri Chamanbhai
Vora
other dignitaries
on and off the dais
my friends
brothers and sisters
First of all
I must
acknowledge
the dedication the sincerity with which
all the three organizations particularly
Islam Research Foundation has taken
pains in arranging this lecture. I am
don't mind and I don't hesitate in
saying the entire credit goes to IRF.
Friends,
the topic today
is
non-veg food
permitted or prohibited
for a human being?
Any argument or any statement, for that
matter,
is always to be considered from a
relative point of view.
There cannot be any absolute truth.
Okay, there cannot be any absolute
statement that it is 100% prohibited or
100% permitted.
So, friends,
let's see.
As very rightly put in by Mr. Trivedi
who started the ball rolling,
that
we'll not speak
only from religious point of view.
Religious has to enter. You can't uh
um
divorce it from today's subject. But,
I would like to
speak on this topic
that
non-veg food is prohibited
for human being from various angles.
For example,
geographical reason,
historical reason,
moral, ethical, and religious reason,
economical,
environmental, and ecological reasons,
natural reasons and psychological
reasons, and above all,
medical reasons.
It's a fact now well established
that our actions are controlled
by our thoughts.
What we think
we act. And our thoughts are controlled
by our diet.
As we eat, so we behave.
And that's why
the topic is very important
that we should choose our diet in such a
way that
our thinking
is positive.
In the word positive will include
everything.
And
believe me, friends,
not only all the religions, but
the medical science has now proved
that
the food that we take it definitely
influences our thinking
and so our behavior.
Friends, there was a time
when
there was no alternative vegetable
available. As Mr. Trivedi rightly put,
there were places on this world
and there are even now places where
there is no availability of vegetation.
It is simply not possible because of the
extreme circumstances.
But
now the world has progressed so much
that
there is
a very advanced
system of transportation which is
available to us.
And
any type of commodity, including food,
can be transported from one part of the
globe to another without any problem.
Now that
when we have got alternatives, we have
to think about this
which alternative is better
from all the angles that which I have
described earlier.
And that's why, friends,
I am now coming to my topic proper that
non-veg food is not permitted now
at this
point of time
not only for India
but for other countries of the world
also.
First of all
I will
say
that all Indian philosophies
have stated
that
we should
not harm
any living being
not only the living beings that we can
see
but also those living beings which we
cannot see which are in air, fire
water etc. But
always there is a limit. It's very
difficult for a human being
to refrain from total
ahimsa total himsa or violence
because
of his
needs.
So that is why
Lord Mahavir stated
that
at least
you limit the essential cleaning
killings but absolutely no killing for
your own selfish motive or for your own
needs of hunger etc.
And that is why
under Jainism
and most of the Indian philosophies
non-veg food is totally prohibited.
Now this is
a religious aspect. I will not go very
deep into it.
But
the psychological aspect
the effect that
non-veg food has on our thoughts and
deeds that is the most important part.
The learned authors I will not now quote
the names of the books and authors
because that will take time but I have
got all the authorities with me.
It is said that veg diet reduces
needless suffering in the world and also
preserves our ecosystem.
See,
when I talk about alternative, you look
here. Uh you look at the wild animals
who stay in jungle.
They
those who are carnivorous, they will
restrict themselves to meat eating only.
But those animals
which are herbivores,
they will never go for
meat eating.
Only human being is such because of
some
false notions, I will say.
It is the human being has
been both a carnivorous and herbivorous.
As I said, if alternative is available,
why should we go for unnecessary
killing?
The basic principle underlying this
theory is non-violence, love, and
compari- compassion for animals, birds,
fish, etc.
Because flesh food
falls in not essential category, while
vegetarian food comes under essential
category.
Psychologically also,
cruelty,
instant impulses, urges, basic animal
instincts, impatiences are all the
necessary consequences of flesh food.
By eating animal flesh,
men will ingest all the animal
instincts. The four basic animal
instincts of food, fear, possessiveness,
and reproduction. These are there in
men. I don't say no, but
they are the basic instincts.
We have got a reasoning mind. We can
rise above these basic intings
instincts. We can control our impulses
and urges and become Then only we can
become super animals or super beings.
Otherwise,
human being and animals, there is no
difference at all.
But man has additional quality called
reasoning mind, which is blunted by the
influence of flesh food, and man becomes
more like animal.
The scientific reason for this is that
flesh is an integral part of animal
body. It is full of tamasic value. There
are three types of values: tamasic,
rajasic, and satvic.
Tamasic, in short, is the brutal sense
or brutal instincts of animal.
A man
becomes more like an animal,
he's callous, he's cruel,
he's ignorant, if
he is
eating the food
that is the part of the bodies of the
dead animals.
The crime rate is higher. Aggression in
the natural is the natural consequences
of flesh food. It distorts the thinking
and reasoning. It is not only a problem
by itself, but it creates many other
problem, like increase in crimes,
cruelty, etc.
The virtues like compassion, sharing,
self-control are obliterated by the
import of impact of flesh food.
If we insist on treating animals more
brutally,
then our behavior will also become
less human and more brutal.
I will quote one shairi, that what will
happen
if this animal instincts
is so embedded in our heart,
what will become of man?
Adami
ki shakl se ab dar raha hai se ab dar
raha hai adami. Adami ko lut kar ghar
bhar raha hai adami.
Adami hi marta hai, mar raha hai adami.
Friends,
this is because
the man has become an animal. He does
not then distinguishes between whether
he is an animal or a human being because
this is the influence of the food, the
flesh food that he eats.
Flesh food is the cause of PMS syndrome,
that is preposterous mood swing
and psychological distortions. Thus, it
is now established that if flesh food is
the root cause of moral and spiritual
degeneration.
We at Indian Vegetarian Congress we are
working
for important task since it will lead to
a more humane world at peace with animal
kingdom and with each other.
We at IBC define a vegetarian as one who
does not at any time or under any
circumstances eat meat, fish, fowl,
eggs, or any other
type of
flesh food.
Vegetarian does not come from vegetable.
Now, this is very important friends,
understand. The word vegetarian does not
come from vegetable.
It the root is it is derived from the
word vegetus, v e g e t u s, meaning
whole,
sound,
fresh, lively.
Nothing is more powerful than an
individual acting out of his conscience,
thus helping to bring the collective
conscious to life, that is what Norman
Cousins said.
And what does Albert Schweitzer has to
say?
Until man extends his
circle of compassion to all living
things, man will not find peace for
himself. It is a man's sympathy with all
creatures that first makes him
truly a human being.
Now friends,
I will go
next
to the most important topic
and that is
the medical viewpoint.
It's a fallacy friend.
It's a myth
to say that we don't get enough protein
from veg food and that is why a man must
have flesh food
that is rich in protein.
I'll come one by one to these myths.
First of all, I will first give you
examples of those strong animals.
Say elephant.
Say rhino.
These are the strongest animals on this
earth.
Are they meat eaters? No. They are your
veg. Even if they die, they will not eat
meat.
Even then, they are the strongest. Take
example of horse.
We call of we talk about horsepower.
It's the most powerful creature useful
for our purpose
and that is also a pure vegetarian. And
take examples of cattle, cows,
bullock,
and other animals. They are not only
useful to us, but
they are pure vegetarian. My point here
is that those
vegetarian animals are strong enough and
they don't need any flesh food. In fact,
if
stupidly
flesh food is given
to these veg animals, what will happen?
You all know about the mad cow disease,
the symptom called BSE.
Friends,
this BSE, bovine spongiform
encephalopathy.
You know what happened a few years back
in England?
It was a result of feeding rendered
sheep byproducts to cattle as protein
supplement, these sheep were infected
with scrapie and a seed disease known
for over 200 years.
Now, if sheep food
can make a cow mad,
what do you expect the result on human
being?
Millions of innocent cows were killed
mercilessly just because they were
suspected to be infected with BSE and
that too for no fault of theirs, but the
stupid ways of feeding sheep protein on
absolutely un- unnatural diet for a cow.
So, is the case with humans. Animal
protein is not natural for us.
Similarly, millions of chicks were
destroyed in Eastern Asia countries
because they were infected with certain
disease.
Now, coming back to healthy diet,
I will quote from one Dr. Dean Ornish
who has written a very
learned book on how to reverse heart
disease without surgery or drugs.
And
this book, my friends, is the best
seller in America now.
It has really created interest in the
people of America and all over the world
for that matter that veg food is
definitely better from medical point of
view.
He has given two types of diet.
One, reversal,
and one, prevention of heart disease.
Both are strictly veg diets because he
has proved scientifically that veg food
is the best food for a human being.
It not only helps heart patients, but
also reduces risk of other
degenerating and fatal diseases caused
by flesh food,
diseases like cancers of colon,
cancers of breast, cancers of prostate,
obesity, high blood pressure, stroke,
diabetes, gallstones. The Surgeon
General of America has confirmed this in
the report on nutrition and health. He
has given certain facts for protein.
Friends, we'll have to be a little
technical about it.
The protein is formed from building
blocks called amino acids.
These are of million varieties, of which
only three are critical for us. Lysine,
tryptophan, and methionine. All these
are available in animals as well as veg,
plant food. But, when one consumes
animal food for getting these three
critical amino acids, one also consumes
a unnecessary
elements like cholesterol, saturated
fat. Friends, these are the two things
that are
the prime reason, the killers for human
being. Cholesterol and saturated fat.
Now, let us address the issue that is
universally put forward that we do not
get sufficient protein from vegetarian
food. And so, we have to turn to flesh
food for adequate supply of amino acids.
Now, this is a fallacy. A combined meal
of legumes and cereals,
legumes means dal,
pulses,
and cereals mean
wheat, rice, etc. You have to combine
these two and you get a complete
balanced diet which provides complete
protein which is not different from
protein found in eggs or meat, but
without cholesterol and animal
instincts.
One diet
One dietetic association has stated
positive relationship between vegetable
lifestyles and risk reduction for
several chronic degenerative diseases as
mentioned earlier. It has confirmed that
veg diet is healthier and more
nutritious.
Plant food is totally free from
cholesterol,
which is only found
It is which is found in both, but
cholesterol is only found in animal
products such as meat, poultry, fish and
dairy. Fresh food is also high in
saturated fats, which our which our
liver converts into cholesterol.
Our body makes all the cholesterol we
need. Now, this is very important,
friends. You must understand. We don't
have to We need cholesterol, but we
don't have to take cholesterol from
animal food. Our body, it's a wonderful
mechanism. The biochemistry, the
chemical factory of our body can
manufacture all proteins, all
cholesterol from our own system. 3/4 of
the cholesterol in our blood is made by
our body. It is the excessive amounts of
cholesterol and saturated fat in the
diet that lead to coronary heart
disease.
The other diseases, friends, which I
have summarized from various journals,
medical journals,
epilepsy, infected flesh,
kidney diseases, excessive protein,
excessive uric acid. These are all the
diseases because of the flesh food.
Rheumatoid arthritis, gout.
This is the
direct consequence of uric acid found in
flesh food.
Degeneration of intestines, decay in
immunity system.
Dr. Deepak Chopra of America has stated
that our body
is capable of living for more than 100
years if we take proper care of it. Now,
look at the
um population in uh
north
extreme north region, Eskimos.
Now, perforce, because no vegetation is
available, they have to take flesh food.
And the average life of an Eskimo is
only 30 years.
All non-veg food is devoid of vitamin C
and vitamin A, which is naturally
available in vegetables.
Avidin in eggs and other dangerous
bacteria are responsible for many skin
diseases such as eczema, scabies,
leprosy, etc.
Now, I'll give you a certain scientific
facts.
One medical study has proved that there
are less heart diseases in veg people
than flesh eaters.
It's second, it's a well-known fact that
not only in India, but even in advanced
countries, there is no foolproof system
of medical exam of animals before
slaughtering. Thus, diseases carried by
them are passed on to the humans who eat
flesh food. Friends, we all know that
like human beings,
the animals are also infected by
diseases. And they are the
carriers of the deadliest germs. And
when these animals they die and one eats
that flesh, that diseases which were
infected and which were the part of the
dead body of that animal is again
inherited by us.
9% of food poisoning cases, 90% of food
poisoning cases are in flesh food
eaters.
When an animal or bird is brought to a
slaughterhouse, now this is a friend
which is again, it needs some
explanation.
If you have ever visited a
slaughterhouse or a poultry, you will
know this. When the animals are brought
to the slaughterhouse,
and when they know that they are going
to be slaughtered,
the the pain,
the agony,
the anguish
that runs in the system, it gives rise
to adrenaline, the hormones, which mixes
with the blood and into the flesh. Now,
these instincts of
fear, anguish, anger, despair, all
negative points are then
becoming part of the flesh food and it
passes on to the person who eats. And
that is why, friends, I say that when
one eats flesh food, he becomes more
like animal and less like a human being.
I will now
turn to
the fallacy
that eggs are necessary for growing
children because they contain protein.
As I said, excessive protein is more
harmful than useful.
And
the protein that we find in pulses, in
cereals, is much more richer and natural
than the protein the excessive protein
we find in animal food.
Now, I'll give you the example of a egg.
Each egg weighs about 100 g and has 170
calories.
It contains 13.6% of protein.
As against that, any dal or pulse will
contain 24%
of protein, much more than the egg of
same